ma che ne sappiate ragazzi è legale in
italia avere dei capelli così ma perché
sembra che mi abbia beccato una vacca
stamattina set e triste quella giunti
ragazze pervenute questo video sono
faringei ed oggi siamo subito in teoria
dovrebbe essere un blog però non faccio
fare rispondere non facciano scartato di
pacchi perché è uscito l'aggiornamento
di snapshot e devo capire con voi
l'ignoranza di questa cosa
e adesso è uscito aggiornamento quindi
le basi e aprì snapshots grazie ecco
l'anno aggiornata adesso capisce le cose
in fantastiche sono un mago ho creato un
tunnel spazio tempo infinito ma che roba
come si fa ragazzi che non mi ricordo
più dio che la mia faccia e giallo
horror così quindi partiamo bene si può
a 4 per cento madonna quanta roba hanno
aggiunto dai proviamo prima casa
apri la bocca oddio cos'è starò 9 non
sono carino ragazzi d'aver sono
diventato cat mario sa cosa mi ami è
orribile guarda che ciò che con certe
rosa nei bellissimi viene da schiacciare
e concetti muoio muoio di cui un giorno
e che bello scrive no che è successo per
un attimo persone i poteri da gatto
siccome sono un gatto poi cargo sulla
lettiera per adesso sono così che la
scuola ipad ma ragazzi stessi successivo
dai ragazzi è diventato apri la bocca è
vabbè geniale genialissimo e poi non
capisco perché aprono la bocca però
spara dagli occhi c'è non ha senso di
aprono la bocca avrebbe spara a borca
non dagli occhi e se l'impresa testa
peperonata trattamento
dentro lo sento lo sento dopo avere sto
potere quando andava a scuola li
mortacci miri facciamo saltare in area
l'aula proprio fantastico io ho sempre
saputo che le ragazze adorano i ragazzi
occhi azzurri
sempre che abbiano gli occhi nel punto
giusto procura un altro discorso ma
mavalà anni occasine questi occhi ci
regali ragazzo li passiamo al prossimo
prima di dichiarare guerra al kazakistan
se cos'è c'è una benda fantastico ma che
cazzo però sono stata anche l'incipit di
ariel fantastico io lacrima e acqua
dagli occhi e kevin in onda tutta la
stanza fantastico che bei pesci che
bello sto piangendo dal sopracciglio mi
spiegate il senso di quel vi prego
voglio capire il mio gruppo la prova
complimenti hanno questo mi rende solo
più carino farabello per rendere più
carino merci vuole un trapianto manco
platinette si è già un etna se non te ne
sei accorto che è grave quindi non so
quanto possa aiutare un effetto di snap
già ci vuole proprio uno scalatore
alpino che kamelot cavi via ecco questo
mi esalta le grilli che so cornuto è la
cosa più oscena che io abbia mai basta
vomitare arcobaleni oddio ma intanto
l'arcobaleno ma la mia faccia che si
deforma che è fantastica dell ex pazzo è
dunque è la mia testa è quello so che i
capelli possono indurre a sbagliare però
la mia testa e questa è corsa che un
santo gesù cos'è questo abominio è nei
guai
ma quanto sono belle passiamo al bello
adesso mi piace
ecco questo me l'ha fatto sparire
bruford rinuncio più cos'è ed io ho
mangiato del limone dall'occhio e mi si
è ristretto il cervello ragazzi che
cazzo è diventato un gioco horror questa
che espressione dativo che poi rimorchio
le quarantenni ma quando ragazzi se se
io prendo questo libro mio
oddio ma no ma veramente bene
cos'è sta roba già la bocca aperta
quindi posso anche fare questo no o
santo dio ragazzi libri uccidono
l'ho sempre detto io che i libri cinema
cosa ma come no vabbè ragazzi bellizio
dei salti chi è mio libro provi con
snapshots a fare questa cosa vi prego e
geniale possa far uscire la mummia che
in me fantastico no aregai e bellissimo
sta cosa geniale è che dormono così la
copertina del libro sarebbe più stata
molto più figo qualcos'altro che la poca
aperta da poter fare così e anzi e
allora aspetta mia madre l'ha sempre
detto che sono un bambino letale che ero
un bambino letale ex sembra piagne
quando non mi trovavano i giochi sempre
così finiva ragazzi ho capito che posso
usare queste cose anche con gli oggetti
fantastico mi ha cambiato la vita sta
roba
oddio m1 ficcato la faccia nel fango
ecco io uscivo così quando prendevo i
quattro a scuola mia mamma mi riempiva
di schiaffi e finivo così uguale apre la
bocca anche se faccia di merda da marte
solo qua la faccia quella il mio culo va
beh che ce la faccia da culo bravo ma
questa la mia listerine
spazio di ai batteri che lui spazio di
la mia mamma mi dice che sono vegano e
non posso mangiare la carne e le cose
degli esseri viventi perché fanno ma la
cosa bella ragazzi che la faccia e tutta
sporca pro i denti scintillano si fa per
dire ai ragazzi all'attore esce del fumo
che non ho capito se sto scoraggiando
cose prove e passiamo al prossimo allo
zero chiuse non è bruttissimo vizio
avete presente quando uscite che fa
freddo e vi si increspa alla faccia ci
avete le crosticine ek
ma sti caxxi prove o dio è imprese no
ragazze mi fa impressione sta cosa posso
spostarmi la maschera
togliti al cazzo vangol niente la non si
toglie o 70 76 tolta l'ho tolta goiana
quella nera boca e l'occhio la bocca e
questa prova ragazze di tra verità che
sono più figo così allora addio
oddio che devo aprire la bocca ma cos'è
spara alle stelle ragazza allora neanche
sotto effetto di lsd succedono cose cioè
non è normale ragazzotti avete presente
quando provate ad approcciare con una
ragazza e provate a tirar fuori il
vostro sguardo da george clooney
benissimo dimenticatevi se stronzate
perché non servono bene da ad essere
avanti e ci sono gli occhiali da
rimorchio quando state mangiando un
hamburger con cipolla con la vostra
ragazza vicino e vi avvicinate a lei
l'ha guardato dritto negli occhi e con
sicurezza esclamate mai più scene del
genere con i nuovi occhiali craxi 2000
al posto del rutto uscirà fuori la
canzone dt
allora ragazzi ha concluso con i miei
all in con gli effetti fantastici di
disney
prima di concludere passo le news che
c'è un paio di robben a dirvi passiamo
alla normalità che non è questa anche se
sono più bello così però non è questa
quindi ragazzi questo era il mio video
su snapshot è stato tragico adesso con
il nuovo aggiornamento di snap
trasmetteranno i miei capelli che
compaiono sulla gente e la gente si
spaventa perché queste fan paura anche
ragazzi prima di concludere il dragone o
solo dirvi due cose importanti la prima
ragazzi e che siamo arrivati a un
milione di follower su instagram
vi ringrazio di cuore perché un altro
traguardo di un milione in un altro
social che non c'entra niente quindi
grazie di cuore ragazzi e la seconda con
ragazzi ancora più importante è che il
30 di gennaio farà una live cosa che non
faccio da da da secoli con l'al ain
ragazzi possiamo giocare insieme io
registrerò un video in diretta che andrò
su youtube in diretta cioè nel senso che
moralmente lo sto registrando voi vedete
cosa sto facendo cioè in line per sala i
ragazzi giocherò tutto il pomeriggio 30
gennaio tutto pomeriggio a tre diversi
videogame e li giocherò in diretta con
voi nel senso che anche voi potete
partecipare alla mia partita e giocare
con me apparire nel video live che farò
se volete apparire nel video giocare con
me scaricatevi giochi che andrò a fare
ve li lascio qui descrizione con con i
link per scaricarli scaricatevi le
giacche così il 30 gennaio ce l'avete
già tutti e tre è un evento tipo gli
oscar quelli di quella live perché la
live non la faccio da da secoli con che
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto e cosa
è giusta video è piaciuta sono momento è
un mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
e con essa è colpa di snapshot anche la
pagina di facebook e come invito a
trattare iscrizione partecipate tutti
alla live se non siete nelle persone
brutte brutte propri dentro soliti di
sky poi ci vediamo subito
[Musica]